Cal Ripken you can help Cal Ripken jr.
the Cal Ripken senior foundation its
partners launch strike out hunger 2020
feeding America lend a helping hand
during the challenging times join them
by donating at Ripken foundation.org /
donate / strikeout hunger rip how are
you today I'm doing really good it's uh
if I could just say in a real quick
thing you did a really nice job of
giving all with details but our
foundation has helped kids all across
the country and now we've shifted our
focus temporarily to help the food and
security and I couldn't be prouder of
our foundation we put in a hundred
thousand dollars our partners put in
another 150 and I think other partners
are adding money right now so we got a
really good start what we want to help
as many kids as we can and that's all
I'm asking for is a little help one
dollar given is ten meals distributed so
five dollars ten dollars can go a long
way awesome awesome
that's great to talk to you I don't know
if you watched the rear of your game
last night on ESPN when you broke Lou
Gehrig's all-time record
have you watched I did I realized last
night that I hadn't watched it in its
entirety you know from start to finish
and listen to a Chris Berman and buck
Martinez that was that was kind of fun
and then listening to a weaver and John
biller and everybody else and it's all
it's actually fun I like going back and
looking at myself in because I was kind
of skinny but to see the other guys to
see Chris Berman how youthful he looks I
mean it's 25 years ago does that happen
it's amazing
you gave your jersey and hat to your
family huh now it was that to make sure
it didn't go to the Hall of Fame that
you wanted to keep it like no okay no
the I was given by my kids that morning
black t-shirts at 2131 hugs and kisses
for daddy and my my daughter was five
and my board was two and so I wanted I
wanted I didn't really have it figured
out but I wanted to show them that I
wore my Jersey I mean if I wore the
t-shirt underneath and I was thinking
about unbuttoning and kind of showing it
to him and then I got the idea in the
that 22 minute ovation I kept coming out
embarrassed to say thank you all those
times in a row but I came out and I took
my jersey off and I asked which the
clubhouse got to go get my another
Jersey in my locker and so I brought
this Jersey out and gave it to him but
the whole design was so they could see
that I wore the t-shirt okay cuz I I
wasn't sure but that you took it off and
then I noticed Rafael Palmeiro and Bobby
Bennett like they were saying go back
out there like I think after the second
one you're like I'm a little
uncomfortable here with a girl talking
about that I remember it that Robert
Raphael and Bobby Bo were the two people
but if I really remember correctly it
was Ralphie's idea Bobby Bo took
ownership of it and one pushed me out
there definitely Hammonds was in on that
I think Leo Gomez was there and I think
we all didn't know what to do
you know nobody could have written that
sort of script but we were saying you
know God you know we got to get this
game going on I was kind of embarrassed
that you know Mike Mussina was pitching
and it was like a long rain delay for
him and and then they said you got to
take a lot of time but I'm not taking a
lap around this park and I might even
said that's a dumb idea
and then when they pushed me down there
you know and I started to see people's
faces that I knew I started to see some
people that I knew their names and then
the celebration turned from this huge
outpouring you know from the from upper
decks and lower decks into a real
intimate celebration so that it was uh
it was pretty amazing but what was
bizarre though rip is we knew that it
was going to happen it wasn't like you
were Kirk Gibson and you just homered
off Dennis Eckersley in the World Series
it was hey let's this is gonna be an
official game when it's an F it's an
official game and then all of a sudden
they're like let's go crazy it's an
official game congratulations
counter-hit kid you kind of summed it up
pretty good I didn't know this but I was
talking to Tim Curran yesterday and Tim
Curran said you know at game number 2008
they started the banner on the warehouse
and I remember the first time the banner
on the warehouse they started playing
this music when the game became official
whether it's four and a half
was five depending upon if you were head
or not and then all of a sudden the the
number would fall down and it would be a
new number on the warehouse and so the
it almost brought the fans along at to
that moment of the number dropping which
created its own drama in itself so you
know and I think it was just an
accumulation of you know all the years
and I think personally one of the things
that I enjoyed most about that year-long
celebration was that everybody related
to you know showing up they related to
the work ethic of a perfect attendance
in school or never missing a day of work
or they took pride in that so I heard
everybody's streaks that they had in
their own lives and I and I thought that
was pretty interesting that you know we
as athletes I could never be a
basketball player and guard Shaquille
O'Neal down low because you know you
don't have the size in baseball it seems
like you can be any size and it's
interesting that a work ethic or how you
go about your job everybody can relate
to that as well so that was really fun
for me did you ever miss you know school
because you were sick yeah oh you did
I didn't here's the amazing part is that
because I didn't miss a game people
think that I have this obsession and I
had perfect attendance in school and
everything was but I always laugh
because you know people looked at not
missing a day at work and I go that's a
real streak and I say cuz I don't work
yeah you know I play a game for a living
I don't have to grow up and you can be a
kid until you're in my case 41 but how
do you avoid any injury though that
that's the I mean there's a little bit
of luck I don't know how much strategy
but you're playing shortstop
there's plays at you know second base
you know you I don't know how many times
you got hit by a pitch during that
streak but it's amazing that you could
get hurt in any number of ways and the
freakiest sort of ways there was many
people that were on there on
disabled as things that they did at home
and so I remember People magazine was
asking me do I not cut up my own food do
I you know do I not used knives do I so
there were different things that they
were asked me to kind of avoid home
accidents but the truth of the matter is
I did get injured I mean everybody that
plays the game is going to have nagging
injuries and you and you have to deal
with a certain amount of nagging
injuries if I play 162 or somebody plays
152 or 145 it's a similar sort of
feeling all the way through I did have a
good set of genes I healed really well
so if I had a line drive off my instep
you know hit a ball down on my foot you
know it would hurt like nobody's
business but when you look at it the
next day I didn't have the swelling and
I didn't have what other people could
hit a ball up their foot it could swell
up and then they couldn't move their
foot or ankle and they would go on and
disable us so I had a good set of jeans
but the best part about it is when you
do play through an injury and then you
force yourself to go through and then
there's light on the other side and you
do well then you then you have
confidence that the next time that
happens you can do it so I always
thought the key to anyone playing all
those games in a row do it once and if
you finish strong in September you've
answered the question whether you're
capable of doing it or not and then it's
just a matter of keeping that same
approach each and every year now before
I let you go help me understand how
baseball could pull this off where they
could get all 30 teams in Arizona and
play a baseball season you know if you
put on your analytic analytical brain
which I can't turn off the hurdles and
the challenges are almost intimidating
to you know sort of an idea like that
but I think I step back a little bit I
was happy my first reaction was I was
happy that major league baseball is
working so hard to bring it back in some
shape or form so I guess given the fact
that if we can have it in some form
because I do think baseball is healing
in some ways sport is healing to to all
of us in our day-to-day lives I
witnessed that and I would have never
thought in after 9/11 the role that
baseball played in that short term I
thought was pretty pretty
phenomenal allow us to distract to to
dive into you know baseball and and and
and I think in this case none of us have
been through anything like what we're
going through now and and so I I look
for some signs of normalcy and and for
my world I'd love to see the guys back
on the field playing baseball in some
way shape or form so you know I could
get that in my daily life good luck here
ripped and great to talk to you it's
strikeout hunger 2020 with Cal Ripken
great to talk to you hope you're doing
well dad hey Dad how are you doing
through all this I often wonder you know
everyone's work is affected you guys can
do things digitally and you know you
know you can you can still go on but you
don't have all the information that's
the content that usually have yeah it
makes it a little bit more challenging
but I think it's brought us closer
together with my guys because now we're
in constant contact now we're looking
for things that are interesting to us
and you hope interesting for your
audience
so you're just each day you think
differently than taking it for granted
that hey I'm gonna recap what LeBron did
last night yeah you know then you go
like I have Hank Aaron on later today I
have the Oregon basketball player a
Sabrina I ask you will talk the NFL
draft you know see you're you're just
kind of bouncing around it's a game of
pinball every day but it's a different
game of pinball so you'll be better off
as a result of this yeah in some ways
you have an optimistic view yes yes I'm
a five-tool announcer here yes you are
Thank You rep all right that's Cal
Ripken jr.